pourvu que ça dure vous est présenté par
echodds echorganisme qui agit pour une
économie respectueuse de
[Musique]
l'environnement
bonjour bienvenue dans pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend l'éch
responsable sur public sa révolution
numérique intelligence artificielle
robotisation transition écologique le
marché du travail vit des
bouleversements sans précédent et comme
à chaque révolution industrielle des
métiers sont envoyés à disparaître
tandis que de nouvelles professions
émerge vous verrez alors le marché du
travail est-il prêt comment préparer les
actifs à ses filières d'avenir reportage
dans un incubateur de compétences au
Havre qui forme un nouveau métier de
l'hydrogène et puis vers quelle
profession orienter nos enfants pour les
préparer au futur notre système éducatif
est-il adapté au nouveau défis réponse
avec Arana Gonzales Deen de la Paris
School of international affair à Science
Po pourvu que ça dure émission spéciale
nouveau métier c'est
[Musique]
parti comment les nouveaux outils
technologiques impacte-t-il le monde du
travail réponse avec vous Laurent
Blanchard bonjour bonjour directeur
général France de page group 75 % ce
chiffre est très intéressant 75 % des
entreprises estiment qu'elles adopteront
l'IA l'intelligence artificielle dans
leurs activités enquête du Forum
économique mondial l'IA est en train
deevenir incontournable on vit une
bascule de l'histoire oui euh
indiscutablement il y a beaucoup d'
d'enquêtes qui paraissent sur ces sujets
et selon toute
vraissemblance plus de la moitié ou 75 %
entre la moitié et 75 % des postes
seront très impactés par l'IA dans les 5
6 prochaines années donc c'est c'est
véritablement une bascule probablement
au même titre que la révolution
industrielle bon évidemment l'inquiétude
on la voit venir c'est que lia remplace
peu à peu les travailleurs et quelque
part certains diront que ça a déjà
commencé en France on a un précédent
avec l'entreprise enclusive qui a prévu
de licencier 217 employés pour les
remplacer par de l'intelligence
artificielle est-ce que c'est le début
d'une longue série ou pas est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à des licenciés
massif à l'avenir où il faut pas
s'angoisser non plus il y a beaucoup
d'enquêtes sur le
sujeté sur sur enclusive je crois
qu'effectivement c'est un plan qui qui a
pris un peu de de retard si j'ai bien
compris mais il y a beaucoup d'enquête
sur est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle va se substituer aux aux
emplois actuels 300 millions d'emplois
temps plein remplacés nous dit Goldman
sax la banque américaine Goldman sax il
y a d'autres enquêtes qui publient des
résultats inverses en fait il y a autant
de résultats Que
d'enquête donc on sait pas pas on sait
pas je pense effectivement pour
certaines ça générera des nouveaux
emplois qui viendront en sol de net
compenser les emplois disparus pour
d'autres enquêtes ce sera finalement
équivalent en terme d'emploi créé emploi
disparu donc c'est assez difficile de se
prononcer ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
mais c'est vrai qu'on en écémarrage
c'est que il y a pas du tout les plans
de licenciement auquel on peut auquels
on
peut tout cas pour après on comprend que
l'a génère une importante réduction du
coût du travail donc on peut comprendre
aussi que les entreprises soient à terme
et je sais pas où est le terme tenter de
remplacer des salariés par de
l'intelligence artificiel en fait lia
aujourd'hui dans son fonctionnement
c'est avant tout une technique un outil
qui va permettre pour les il y a à peu
près 50 % de cadres en France et de col
blanc qui ont testé lia et 50 % qui
l'ont jamais utilisé pour ceux qui l'ont
déjà utilisé c'est perçu pour la moitié
d'entre eux comme une une manière de se
débarrasser des tâches les plus
fastidieuses et et et aujourd'hui ils
l'entendent plutôt il il l'appréhendent
plutôt comme une sorte de super
assistant que comme un système
qui remplacer le mé c'est pas une menace
et à m'écouter effectivement c'est pas
une menace en fait c'est très difficile
de se projeter on en est au début de
l'intelligence artificielle je pense
qu'il faut le considérer avant tout il
faut considérer lia comme une comme une
opportunité il y a des techniques qui
permettent d'aller broser plus
d'information d'aller broser plus de
Data d'aller proposer des recueils des
des rédactions et et dans plein de
métiers c'est c'est c'est cette valeur
là c'est avant tout du temps à consacrer
plus à de l'analyse plus à d'autres
tâches qu'aux tâches les plus
fastidieuses que peuvent avoir l'école
blanc majoritairement et donc quand on
entend que les métiers surdiplômés à
haut salaire seraient plus menacés que
les bas salaires et peu diplômés c'est
pas c'est pas ce qu'on voit pour
l'instant sur le terrain on peut
comprendre que lia étant plutôt euh
consacré au traitement de l'information
et de la data quelqu'un qui travaille
sur la data a plus de Chan de rencontrer
liia qu'un éoignant ou qu'un chauffeur
de bus donc c'est la particularité
finalement de cette révolution il a par
rapport au révolution industrielle c'est
qu'elle touche plutôt les salariés de
bureau oui que les personnes qui sont
sur le terrain h si on parle des métiers
qui sont en en danger potentiellement on
sait que l'a peut produire plus de code
plus rapidement et donc certains se
disent bah voilà ça peut compromettre
l'avenir des métiers qui impliquent de
la programmation on pense au métiers de
programmateur informatique de
développeur web de Data scientist pour
l'instant on sait ils sont très demandé
sur le marché du travail mais ça
pourrait changer tout peut changer par
nature euh donc finalement moi je suis
pas mê même chat GPT open envisage de
remplacer ses propres ingénieurs
logiciels par de la enfin je veux dire
tout peut changer et je pense que le
potentiel de déploiement de Lia on l'a
pas encore complètement vu donc celui
qui est capable aujourd'hui euh euh de
dire que tel métier va être remplacé je
pense qu'il prend il prend des risques
indiscutablement c'est une évolution
très forte dans la manière de mener
certains métiers et il y aura
probablement des conséquences est-ce que
ce sera du remplacement ou est-ce que ça
permettra aux équipes en place d'aller
plus loin d'être plus performante de
développer de nouvelles applications
d'apporter plus une touche créative on
peut y croire à ce scénario là je pense
qu'on pe je pense qu'on peut
véritablement y croire à la au début de
la de l'aire du digital dans les années
2000-20 et on a traversé cette cette
petite révolution aussi euh il y a il y
a beaucoup de personnes qui nous
racontaent qu'il y a plein de métiers
qui allaient disparaître et qui
finalement se sont plutôt transformés
qu'ils ont disparus et et et au début
encore une fois de la révolution
industrielle il y avait les mêmes il y
avait les mêmes craintes si on regarde
maintenant les les métiers d'avenir déjà
on se dit tous les métiers autour autour
du Big Data évidemment la donnée il y en
a de plus en plus il y a des métiers qui
émergent encore une fois aujourd'ui
aujourd'hui et demain et lesquels il y
en a beaucoup il y en a beaucoup qui
émergent dans le domaine de dans le
domaine de l'IA les premier en fait il y
a trois grandes catégories il y a les
métiers de la data effectivement et et
ça c'est fondamental les Data analystes
c'est plutôt les gens qui vont parle de
nos données hein c'est toutes les traces
qu'on laisse exactement les Data analyes
qui sont dans l'entreprise ils vont
analyser la donnée de l'entreprise les
Data scientist ils vont analyser toute
la data et aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on
est dans un monde de Data tout est
traqué quand on est sur le le web et et
et et eux vont se charger d'analyser
toute cette data qu'on va trouver
partout dans l'espace public pour
essayer de la reformer de la trier et de
la mettre à disposition et d'en faire
des outils d'aide à la décision par
exemple pour les entreprises ensuite il
y a la partie développement parce que
c'est intelligence artificielle et c'est
là que c'est aussi très créateur
d'emploi pour qu'elle fonctionne bah il
faut qu'elle soit nourrie il faut
qu'elle soit structurée si on pense à
des outils de diagnostic médicaux par
exemple comme on peut en trouver
l'intelligence artificielle peut
permettre d'amener plus de scénarios au
médecin qui est chargé d'analyser par
exemple un compte-rendu à diagnostic et
et pour que cette intelligence
artificielle fonctionne il faut à la
fois qu'il ait un spécialiste
scientifique qui structure et puis et
puis un spécialiste médical qui va
fonctionner en binôme et qui va
permettre de d'élaborer un certain
nombre de scénarios par rapport à des
informations collectées donc ça c'est le
métier du développement euh c'est des
développeurs d'IA et puis il y a les
métiers de la gouvernance et et bien
évidemment
tant le Big Data que l'intelligence
artificielle ça pose quand même plein de
questions sur le plan de la
réglementation sur plan sécurité et de
la sécurité sécité ces données ces datas
es sont sensibles et on voit l'explosion
de cette menace cyber qui est de plus en
plus sophistiquée va falloir protéger
protéger nos données il y a des nouveaux
métiers aussi autour de cette
cybersécurité alors on a dit Pen tester
c'est quoi ce Pen tester le Pen tester
c'est le cambrioleur qui est finalement
embauché par le propriétaire de la
maison pour tester sa porte d'entrée et
son système de sécurité ça revient à ça
dans un service informati donc c'est le
hackur de l'Intérieur exactement c'est
un métier qu'on retrouve de plus en plus
le hacking et la cybersécurité c'est une
vraie problématique
aujourd'hui toute entreprise quasiment
d'une certaine taille se fera hacker
dans les 5 prochaines années c'est c'est
devenu quelque chose de très récurrent
et donc les entreprises soit par le
biais de prestataire soit dans le
ressources internes effectivement on des
équipes pour prévenir ce genre de
déboire les entreprises aussi doivent
s'adapter à la donne climatique du coup
bah il y a des postes qui qui se
consolident notamment tout ce qui est
RSE responsabilités sociale des
entreprises directeur consultant RSE a
la demande là oui il y a beaucoup de
demandes euh je crois que dans chaque
PME aujourd'hui PMI il y a une
obligation d'une stratégie RSE parce
qu'une entreprise c'est une marque parce
qu'elle a une responsabilité parce que
les consommateurs les citoyens attendent
d'ell des comportements exemplaires et
aujourd'hui ces entreprises qui font
face à un environnement qui est très
nouveau un environnement législatif qui
est très qui est très mouvant et puis et
puis des attentes qui sont très
nouvelles elles font appel à des
compétences extérieures pour essayer de
de comprendre en quoi leur métier la
manière dont elle exerc peut avoir une
interaction dans le domaine sociétal ou
dans le domaine environnemental et donc
les postes demandés les profils on voit
vraiment des secteurs émergés
aujourd'hui nous en matière de de
recrutement on a une grosse partie de
notre activité sur les les métiers
ingénieur les métiers de production les
métiers d'exploitation et on voit
émerger des secteurs d'activité qu'on ne
voyait pas il y a 2 ans la grriille
voltaïsme par exemple c'est quelque
chose dont on avait pas entendu parler
il y a 2 3 ans à la base c'est une c'est
un complément d'activité pour des des
entreprises agricoles qui vont se servir
de leurs infrastructures pour produire
de l'énergie on voit des panneaux
solaires sur les toit sur les TR des
fermes et la revendre exactement et
finalement d'une activité euh
complémentaire euh certains sont en mode
reconversion et puis il y a de nouveaux
acteurs avec des levés de fond qui vont
utiliser des Bâ btim existant pour aller
produire de l'électricité et la revendre
donc là on a un secteur d'activité
véritablement nouveau avec des nouveaux
métiers ouais et donc cette transition
écologique
elle peut-être on l'espère positive très
positive pour l'emploi et créatrice
d'emploi elle est elle est très
créatrice d'emploi aujourd'hui la
transition écologique parce que comme on
est sur des techniques nouvelles qu'on
parle d'agrivoltaïsme qu'on parle
d'hydrolien par exemple ou ou d'éolien
quand on implante des champs d'éoliennes
offshore bah forcément faut des gens
pour les concevoir faut des gens pour
les installer et puis il faut de grosses
équipes de maintenance des techniciens
des ingénieurs spécialisés dans la
maintenance de genre d'équipement c'est
très créateur d'emploi et puis si on
parlait du nucléaire alors on pourrait
débattre sur sur sur l'énergie nucléaire
elle est en tout cas euh catalogué bac
cararbone il y a aujourd'hui dans la
filière nucléaire 10 à 15000 postes par
an créés et et et ça jusqu'au à peu près
dans les années 2030 donc c'est très
créateur d'emploi allez Merci à VOUS
Laur ch directeur général France de page
group merci merci beaucoup on va
continuer à parler de formation mais
justement comment préparer les actifs
mais aussi les jeunes à ses filières
d'avenir reportage signé manuel re face
à la révolution numérique et écologique
qui s'annonce les métiers sont appelés à
évoluer mais sommes-nous prêts à relever
le défi rien que dans les métiers des
énergies propres les création d'emploi
ont surpassé cell des énergies fossiles
et la tendance pourrait s'accentuer
solaire éolien hydraulique transport
électrique batterie pompe à chaleur
métau critique il faudrait deux postes
dans les énergies vertes pour remplacer
chaque emploi perdu dans les énergies
fossiles mais alors comment recruter et
former massivement la main d'œuvre de
demain quelles seraient les conséquences
si la France ne parvenait pas à prendre
le virage de l'énergie
verte depuis quelques mois l'éducation
nationale contre-attaque alors ici
est-ce qu'on avance
comme à banieux au lycée professionnel
Léonard de Vinc quand ça sera vraiment
sousension tu vas faire la même chose et
c'est comme ça qu'on a les erreurs 40000
km de réseau ne9f à installer chaque
année 1 million de voitures électriques
à alimenté d'ici 2027 ou encore 13
nouvelles lignes de RER autant de
projets gourmands en énergie qui
nécessiteront toujours plus de main
d'œuvre on est déjà sous très forte
tension la croissance du secteur elle
est telle que on a déjà de la peine à
recruter en France c'est 100000 emplois
1600 entreprises et nous allons recruter
tous les ans 8300 personnes parmi les
100 métiers de l'électricité 30 %
d'entre eux sont déjà sous tension alors
pour gonfler les rangs enedis travaille
main dans la main avec les lycées
professionnels objectif attirer les
jeunes plutôt dans la filière féminiser
la profession et capter les candidats en
reconversion les investissements ont été
conséquents avec du matériel qu'ils
utilisent sur leur plateau technique ça
permet que nos élèv soit davantage formé
au-delà de l'aspect technique enedis
aide les élèves à trouver un stage en
entreprise et promet même une embauche à
la clé mais si autant de moyens sont
déployés ça ne serait pas uniquement
dans l'intérêt du gestionnaire des
réseaux électriques si on arrive pas à
recruter c'est la transition énergétique
qui se fera pas donc euh parce que
aujourd'hui pour réaliser la transition
énergétique il faut développer les
réseaux électriques si on n'a pas les
personnes pour concevoir et construire
ses postessources ben on pourra pas
accueillir euh toutes les énergies
renouvelables toute l'énergie sur le
réseau aujourd'hui 50 lycées
professionnels ont noué un partenariat
avec enenedis et il devrait doubler à la
rentrée scolaire 2024 mais cette filière
n'est pas la seule à poser problème une
autre pourrait manquer cruellement de
main d'œuvre dans les prochaines années
celle de
l'hydrogène certains voient en elle la
solution à tous nos problèmes
énergétiques de l'aviation au transport
en commun en passant par l'industrie
l'hydrogène pourrait largement
contribuer à la neutralité carbone d'ici
2050 là je ne recrche que de l'eau j'ai
de la fumée à l'arrière auudessus et en
dessus du bus cette fumée c'est que de
l'eau c'est il y a rien de polluant
dedans en France sa consommation
pourrait passer de 45000 à 700000 tonnes
par an dans les 10 prochaines années
mais pour parvenir du personnel qualifié
il va en falloir il faudrait pas qu'on
rate la filière hydrogène comme on a
raté la filière solaire on a bon espoir
de d'être dans la Course des Champions
l'enjeu est de taille l'hydrogène c'est
aujourd'hui 6000 emplois et 100000 en
2030 au Havre un centre de formation
compte relever le défi on fait une passe
ici on apprend la soudure classique mais
dans quelques jours les stagiaires
pourront choisir l'option hydrogène une
formation qui leur permettra de
travailler et souder les outils qui
fabriqueront cette nouvelle énergie
hydrogène on doit être un peu plus
méticuleux on doit être un peu plus
ordonné on travaille presque dans un
atelier blanc c'est vraiment un atelier
qui doit rester super propre 260000 €
d'investissement un coup de pouce de
l'État et surtout un outil
révolutionnaire pour former toujours
plus de stagiaires l'État a participé au
financement du du plateau technique et
notamment des postes à souder virtuels
une petite révolution aucune flamme ni
de bruit
assourdissant on voit à l'écran ce que
ce que le stagiaire peut peut apercevoir
en sac àoule comme dans un jeu vidéo le
stagiaire enfile un casque de réalité
virtuelle et se retrouve plongé dans
différents scénarios ok on voit que ta
hauteur buse est bonne tes angles sont
bons ta vitesse d'avance bonne au-delà
de pouvoir répéter les gestes en
parfaite autonomie et à moindre coût ce
simulateur permettrait de gagner 20 % de
temps
d'apprentissage les filière hydrogène et
réseau électrique ne sont pas les seuls
où il faudra muscler les compétences les
énergies décarbonées devraient générer
350000 emplois à horizon
[Musique]
2030 vers quel métier orienter nos
enfants pour assurer leur avenir nos
écoles et nos universités sont à
au monde qui vient réponse avec vous
arancha gonzalz bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous doyenne de la Paris
School of International Affairs à
sciencep ancienne ministre des Affaires
étrangères espagnoles il y a ce chiffre
65 % des enfants qui entrent à l'école
aujourd'hui vont faire un métier qui
n'existe pas encore donc à forceuie leur
formation n'existe pas non plus est-ce
que face à tous ces bouleversements que
l'on vit technologique écologique est-ce
que notre système éducatif français
est-ce qu'il tient la route est-ce qu'il
est pas pardon de dire un peu obsolète
je crois que c'est les défis auquels
c'est sont confrontés aujourd'hui toutes
les systèmes éducatifs au monde je
dirais tout d'abord que dans ces mondes
dans lesquels il y aura des emplois
qu'aujourd'hui on connaît pas on aura
quand même besoin des trois choses qui
étaient essentielles jusqu'au jusqu'à
présent la lecture l'écriture et les
mathématiques donc partons de là et et
partons d'un d'un éclairage qui vient de
nous donner l'OCD comme quoi les
résultats au monde en
mathématique n'avancent pas mais il
reculent donc c'est c'est triple ces
triplle compétences qui qui est savoir
lire et comprendre ce qu'on lit savoir
écrire et les mathématiques resteront
essentiels après comment qu'on se
prépare parce qu'il y a des nouvelles
matières qui Vinent incontournables mais
qui ne sont pas assez voir pas du tout
enseigner et ce qu'il faut dès à présent
en France évidemment et dès le primaire
ou le secondaire musclé les cours de
codage les cours de robotique de
transition énergétique de de
décarbonation je sais pas bon d'abord il
faut apprendre les goûts d'apprendre
ouais parce que on va devoir apprendre
toute notre vie les métiers changent
beaucoup plus rapidement que dans les
passés donc nous allons devoir apprendre
les longes de la vie pas simplement
quand on est des enfants ou des
adolescents tout au long de la vie et
apprendre ces goûts d'apprendre va être
essentiel et qu'est-ce qui va nous faire
avoir ces goûts à mon avis c'est mixer
les connaissances avec les
compétences les les les connaissances
profondes ce qu'on apprend quand on
apprend l'histoire
ou l'économie ou les sciences mais aussi
les compétences comment est-ce qu'on
travaille en équipe comment est-ce qu'on
construit un système c'est quoi une
données comment on peut faire
l'évaluation des données donc à la fois
aussi on parle du primaire de de l'école
mais a aussi les les universités les
grandes écoles est-ce que là aussi le
virage il a été pris est-ce que
l'enseignement actuel au global est à la
hauteur de tous ces défi toutes ces
transitions où est-ce que il faut
falloir inventer de nouveaux cursus je
crois qu'on est tous en train d'inventer
des nouveaux cursus par exemple chez
nous à l'école d'affaires
internationales à Scien po ou bien de
d'inventer un nouveau cursus qui va
s'appeler technologie et affaires
globales oui en quoi double cursus c'est
un double cursus parce que c'est un en
double avec une université en Espagne
donc une université qui est entre les
trois meilleurs au monde en science
politique humaine qui est sciencep avec
une université qui est entre les trois
premières au monde en business et
entreprise à Madrid la somme de deux
pour faire quoi pour comprendre de
quelle manière la technologie est
aujourd'hui en train de façonner les
affaires international l'économie
internationale le droit dans les les
droits numériques
l'espace de débats public les singerac
étrangères la
cybersécurité comment est-ce que cette
technologie aujourd'hui change le monde
des relations internationales donc je
crois que nous sommes tous en train
d'inventer des objets nouveaux je crois
qu'il faut inventer des nouvelles
disciplines par exemple il faut inventer
cette discipline qui est l'humanisme
digital les humanités dans les
digitales la difficulté je crois c'est
que on pourrait pas faire ça simplement
chacun dans son coin ils nous font un
système il faut organiser ces systèmes
il faut organiser ses discipline leur
donner un corpus leur donner un contenu
et aussi comprendre comment ce qu'on va
les évaluer avec une approche
pluridisciplinaire qui est un peu la
marque de fabrique de Scien po Émile
boutmi il y a 150 ans les créateurs des
sciencesp avaient raison
l'interdisciplinaire aujourd'hui est
essentiel il nous faut des ingénieurs
qui sont les meilleurs dans dans la
découverte des systèmes des décryptages
et des décodages et des cybersécurités
mais il nous faut aussi qu'il
comprennent l'importance de l'humain
dans tout ça ou l'éthique dans tout ça
les choix que nous devons faire en tant
qu'ingénieur doiv être des des des choix
aussi à partir de l'humanité et en même
temps à ceux qui s'occupent des sciences
sociale et humaine il faut qu'on
comprenne à quel point la technologie
est importante technolog alors on l'a
dit il y a pas mal de m qui
potentiellement sont voués à disparaître
avec toutes ces ruptures à la fois
technologique en première ligne il y a
les métiers impliquant la rédaction et
donc notamment bah le métier de
journaliste qui est enciené et enseigné
évidemment à science est-ce que est-ce
que vous êtes inquiè est-ce que vous
dites que vous pourriez peut-être à
terme supprimer cet enseignement là ou
pas non je ne crois pas qu'on
supprimera les métiers des journalistes
au contraire il nous faut des
journalistes d'ailleurs il nous faut
beaucoup plus et beaucoup mieux du
journalisme dans nos sociétés ne
serait-ce que pour nous permettre de
mieux construire cet espace de débat
publicque qui est la démocratie
simplement aujourd'hui les journalistes
devront comprendre aussi la manière dont
la technologie impacte les métiers des
journalistes la manière où les
algorithmes nous poussent peut-être à ne
pas poser les bonnes questions ou les
questions dont il faut se poser ou si on
regarde un petit peu les les nouveaux
métiers qui vont prendre de l'ampleur on
l' vu juste avant il y a les métiers du
Big Data la cybersécurité l'intelligence
artificielle est-ce que vous aussi à
sciencep vous vous emparez de tous ces
thèmes toutes ces ces métiers d'avenir
oui qui qui va être les qui va définir
les standards éthiques pour cette
technologie euh ça c'est quelque chose
auquel nous nous travaillons beaucoup
qui va définir les règles pour
l'usage des
des du
cyberespace ou des voitures qui sont
autoconduits euh ou qui va gérer les
trafics des drones h ou qui va définir
les droit dans l'espace donc tout ça
c'est des sujets dans lequels nous
devons inventer de nouveaux des métiers
nouveaux pour lequels il faut former
encore une fois connaissance compéten et
si possible un bon dossage d'expérience
alors au-delà de ces bouleversements
technologiques il y a aussi il faut en
parler cette transition écologique que
nous sommes en train de vivre et qui va
s'accélérer à priori SP est très
impliqué il faut le rappeler aussi pour
former les jeunes dans ce virage vert
c'est ça aussi la réalité hein
absolument et là aussi un très bon
exemple comment nous
devons avancer dans dans les énergies
renouvellables par exemple pour
décarboner nos sociétés pour décarboner
nos économies mais comment il faut le
faire d'une manière juste avec justice
où tous les citoyens peuvent se trouver
où il y a pas certains qui qui vont qui
vont avoir qui vont devoir subir un
impact beaucoup plus large que les
autres sans in compensation dernière
question en matière de formation est-ce
que l'État aussi doit mettre des moyens
plus de moyens il faut certains disent
une espèce de plan Marchal de
l'enseignement de la formation et
d'ailleurs ça passe aussi peut-être
aussi par la la formation des
professeurs des enseignants au passage
aussi donc les financements c'est la
condition nécessaire mais pas suffisante
c'est que euh l'analyse de l'OCDE les
les fameux rapport Pissin nous dit ce
que il faut investir plus dans
l'éducation mais il faut aussi ordonner
un système et ce système veut dire
développer de nouvelles manières de
faire la pédagogie h euh avec plus de
moyens pardon c'est la question des
moyens aussi he se c'est la question des
moyens mais c'est la question des
méthodes aussi donc c'est les moyens et
la manière de faire et la manière est
aussi importante que les moyens donc la
la une un exemple des manières c'est
comment qu'on c'est quoi la pédagogie
aujourd'hui ce n'est peut-être plus euh
un libre avec une classe chapitre 1 2 ou
3 mais c'est plus un organisme vivant
donc méthode pédagogique formation de
professeurs form d'enseignant une
révolution c'est une petite révolution
bien sûr et c'est là qu'il faut déployer
les moyens financiers mais aussi
comprendre qu'on travaille avec des
moyens humains les enseignants et je la
sais bien parce que je viens d'une
famille d'enseignants c'est très
précieux dans nos sociétés il faut
valoriser aussi la fonction des
enseignants la place qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui à former euh nos nos futurs
citoyens nos nos futurs travailleurs euh
nos futurs experts nos futurs savants
Merci à VOUS arancha Gonzales merci
doyenne de la Paris School of
international affair à sencep ancienne
ministre des Affaires étrangères
espagnoles merci à vous plaisir voilà
c'est fin pourvu que c'est dure
l'émission qui rend les corresponsables
émission à voir ou revoir sur public
Sena et en replay sur publicsena.fr
rendez-vous dans 2
[Musique]
semaines pourvu que ça dure vous a été
présenté par e DDS ecoorganisme qui agit
pour une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement